that's right the ECB takes over a
supervisor of the region's top lenders
on November the fourth so its reputation
is really on the line this weekend with
the test results coming out so let's
delve a little deeper on that with a
former investment banker muttonhead wish
now a professor at the Frankfurt School
of Finance and management thank you very
much for coming in what do you think
should the bank's be worried right now I
think we are in a situation where only a
very limited number of banks will fail
in this stress test on the other side
it's also clear it cannot be a stress
test but everybody will be successful at
the end because obviously it's clear
that in the European banking industry is
they are still a number of weak
candidates and it's very important of
these stresses reliable and it then
finally it will be clear that the worst
of these candidates will be identified
at the end very limited so out of 160
just one two or three no but I but I
think it would be a below 10 I think
would not be more finely and it's for me
for example it's not sure if there is
even one German candidate your cash will
fail hey I think it is not sure it can
also happen to everybody and Germany
will be successful at the end it is that
surprising considering that the ECB has
had to shoot down according to some
people countless please from from banks
and from national supervisors for
special treatment within these tests I
think I cannot believe that there
anybody is taking here the risk that
banks in different regions euro will be
treated not equally because that would
be really a hit their reliability of the
stress test vegetation riveters mainly
yeah they're also claims the banks have
failed to provide all the necessary data
now as an investment banker you'd know
there are lots of tricks to the book
some lenders scrambling to hide what
they can I think there probably is not
the data it's more the problem because
we're talking about this a specific term
what are also called risk-weighted
assets how banks are measuring the risk
of the ods attempt on the balance sheet
and here banks are doing that which
internal models and the question is how
these models are calibrated and here it
was an approach of the ECB to make sure
that our internal models are not
calibrated
whether they underestimate risk and that
they line up with the ECB's rulebook
because there are also claims that
supervisors have revised the way they
value assets I mean wouldn't that dent
the tests reputation or also here I I
don't believe that there because
everybody has to work everyone was
involved on supervisory a siren distress
test has worked that there would be a
common playing field yeah so I cannot
believe in this recession so yes or no
you think the exercise is robust and
thorough as the ECB ported sorry you
think the ECB as it puts it is
exercising a robust and thorough test
here yeah I compared to form of stress
tests and that is also important this
dress is definitely a step in the right
direction and so this is also designed
of course to put an end to the crisis of
confidence in European is it going that
step further yeah definitely so also
when we have to compare this stress test
with former stress test it's a step in
the right direction and that banks in
there where F or feeling very nervous
about the odd combo you can see that on
the preparation banks did in the last
couple of years for preparing or the
stress test for example in Germany all
banks near nearly have deleverage the
balance sheet yeah so that means the
banking industry did many preparations
for that I can mr. Hamish will get back
to you in a moment first a closer look
at the role of the European Central Bank
its main purpose of course is to keep
prices stable and also keep the
financial system stable that's what's
been driving Mario Draghi and his
central bank to keep lowering interest
rates to historic tips point zero five
percent it's certainly something to
write home about the other stimulus it's
deploying to try to foster lending to
businesses and support the block is
bond-buying it started buying securities
and there's speculation the ECB could
soon start purchasing corporate bonds on
the secondary market opinions differ
sharply about this man Mario Draghi head
of the European Central Bank his words
move the markets two years ago he said
whatever it takes would be done to
rescue the euro
but in Germany there is resistance to
his policies Draghi's best known critic
is yen's fide man the head of Germany's
central bank the Bundesbank and a member
of the European Central Bank's Governing
Council many economic experts agree with
his criticism like Professor Charles
blank heart issue this time of day and
forth a white man wants a more cautious
policy he wants the individual states to
solve their own problems rather than
relying on eurozone rescue measures does
it so they so his goal is a stricter
policy than draghi's Draghi wants to
simply hand out money for tight
professor hiking up cos in contrast
agrees with dragging she says public
disagreement among central bankers has
negative effects yes positas what's
currently happening is that by mon is
damaging draghi's image and there by
attacking the ECB's credibility and
credibility is the most important thing
for a central bank our whole financial
system is based on trust in the value of
the money the bone of contention is the
European Central Bank's unusual monetary
policy its buying bonds from
crisis-ridden countries but who
ultimately carries the risk its entire
banca central bank is like a normal bank
except that it can't go broke because it
can print money but it has owners for
example Germany owns twenty-seven
percent to the European Central Bank
ultimately the taxpayer is liable for
what the bank does goddess teen that's
beside a tiny bit of risk we carry by
buying government bonds and it's not
even certain that it's a negative risk
it could also lead to big ECB capital
gains I think this tiny bit of risk is
worth taking because the alternative is
really to let the already high
unemployment rate in the eurozone grow
dramatically and that would impact
Germany much more stack up a 12-man
the ECB is going much further it wants
to ease the burden on the national banks
even more by buying some of their high
risk assets this is extremely unusual
behavior for a central bank and so
Draghi is doing what he said whatever it
takes both he and his critics say the
point of this is to rescue the Euro
schmuck if he didn't do that at some
point some country would have to leave
the euro because it would no longer be
solvent and then it in the eurozone
would have to reorganize loi oh honey
see young davina get Adolphe a few
economists believe such a transition
could be coordinated the few who believe
it are not enough you'd have to persuade
all the financial actors what we know
about the past shows that such collapses
of currency zones always proceed with an
extreme lack of coordination so who is
right Mario Draghi who wants to retain
the euro whatever it takes or his critic
yen's fight man is there is who are you
cheering on Draghi or vite man so in
these specific questions what were the
activities of Mario Draghi in the last
couple of years looking on the younger
financial history hi years of southern
European government bonds high funding
rates for banks so i would say mr.
Draghi had no other choice as doing that
what he did and and what he's doing is
is it a step further and actually
helping the banks as so so far it was
not sufficient because of bang for
delivering financial services to ply
needs two things one thing is funding
cheap funding is available but on the
other side they need also risk capital
so for many banks this is indeed the gap
so what Draghi is doing now with the
youngest activities of what the clog is
planning to buying pools of loans from
banks is now the second step which is
also logic to help bank now the risk
capital side tell me how valid is the
point made in that report about vitamin
attacking druggies credibility and and
therefore attacking the credibility of
the ECB on one hand side it's important
that there is an open discussion it's
very clear that there are perhaps
contradicting interests yeah so a white
man do is doing the right things he's
representing the interests of Germany
here on the other side
I do not believe that mr. white man's
activities are destroying his
reliability of these actions but on the
other side I believe that what mario
draghi is doing right now he has no
other options and the debate is all
about buying bonds something that's not
unusual around the world for our other
central banks but how risky is it in
general if the central bank is buying
bonds that is risky for the central bank
it can also by the way in the worst case
end up in a so-called technical default
a central Vegas the central bank cannot
go fall into default in the usual sense
but it can happen at the resort call
technical default and that happens
exactly when all these s that they're
keeping with a balance sheet will have
low values in the future martin image
thank you very much for coming along and
joining us here on made in germany